[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité moins de foie gras
moins de décoration les fêtes de fin
d'année se mettront-elles au régime dans
quelques semaines sur fond de tension
économique Noël pourrait être avoir en
gourmandise cette année reportage à
suivre de via Occitanie et de Tébéo dès
le début de ce journal la fin des
montagnes russes pour les parcs
d'attraction après deux saisons marquées
du Saut du covid les visiteurs
reviennent en masse divertir comme la
constaté Canal 32 dans l'Aube
elles seront 30 après tendre à la
couronne de Miss France le 17 décembre
prochain à quelques semaines du jour J
les miss se prépare à séduire public et
jury reportage en Martinique avec la
rédaction de via ATV dans quelques
instants c'est une spécialité riche et
gourmande des Hauts de France la
rédaction de Wéo TV la chaîne de la Voix
du Nord nous fera découvrir les secrets
du gâteau battus évidemment beaucoup de
sucre et beaucoup de beurre en
perspective
pris à la hausse production à la baisse
le foie gras produit phare des fêtes de
fin d'année se fera-t-il rare sur la
table des Français dans quelques
semaines le sujet préoccupe les
professionnels du secteur confrontés
parallèlement à une forte épidémie de
grippe aviaire et des coûts de
production très élevés explication près
de Perpignan avec ce sujet de Bary Isaac
pour via Occitanie
c'est un produit dont raffole les
Français le foie gras à l'approche des
fêtes nombreux sont les acheteurs comme
ici au soleil mais cette année les prix
honnêtement augmenté alors les
consommateurs sont-ils prêts à payer
plus cher dans une certaine limite on
verra les augmentations le prix au kilo
ce que ça donnera mais effectivement je
me fixerai une limite ah si c'est trop
cher non
si c'est trop cher absolument pas
seulement pour avoir du foie gras mais
aussi pour justement soutenir les
producteurs qui pour qui c'est difficile
cette année le foie gras cru coûte
environ 50 euros le kilo contre 40
l'année dernière ce producteur du Tarn a
vu son stock de foi baissé de 20%
responsable de cette pénurie la grippe
aviaire qui gêne l'approvisionnement des
canetons dans l'ouest de la France
l'augmentation du manque et due aussi au
coût de de l'élevage je crois comme les
céréales doublée alors les prix des
canards en ont augmenté de 52% Claude
vasaï fait partie des cinq producteurs
de canards gras des Pyrénées-Orientales
même si le département est moins
concerné par cette épidémie les
conséquences sont là elle a dû augmenter
ses prix de 10 à
18%, une année difficile pour les
éleveurs qui aura sans doute une
répercussion sur les prix l'année
prochaine on fait nos calendriers
presque un an à l'avance voir sinon six
mois pour commander les petits pour que
ceux qui qui produisent les petits les
mettre en place etc c'est une filière
longue et donc du coup ben il y aura une
incidence de prix et de parce qu'il y
aura peu de quantité face à cette
épidémie de grippe aviaire le ministère
de l'agriculture vient de porter le
niveau de modérer à élever la France
devrait produire 11000 tonnes de foie
gras cette année contre 16000 pour une
année normale
voilà et si le foie gras pourrait se
faire plus discret pour vos repas de fin
d'année les illuminations de Noël ne
sont pas elles n'ont plus épargnées vous
l'avez peut-être remarqué dans les rues
certaines mairies particuliers ou
commerçants ont décidé de baisser la
voilure des décorations pour préserver
leur facture d'électricité bien sûr des
choix pour la sobriété énergétique qui
impacte évidemment les professionnels du
secteur un reportage en Bretagne de
Valérie Leroux colléno pour TBO la
chaîne du groupe telegram sur place
il est l'un des rares fabricants
d'illuminations à confectionner à la
main la magie de Noël celle qui fait
scintiller de nombreuses villes et
villages bretons mais cette année la
crise énergétique assombrit le décor
j'ai pratiquement perdu 40% de des
contrats beaucoup de commerçants en ulés
ainsi que les mairies ont peur
on a enlevé des des motifs de Noël pour
passer sur octobre score a dû être
facturé mais au final
trouver notamment entre l'artisan et la
commune de Saint Thonon qui a tenu à
honorer son contrat mais histoire de ne
pas se faire en guirlandais et évitez
l'écureuil le clocher restera cette
année dans l'obscurité son illumination
habituelle grâce à huit spots était en
effet la plus coûteuse on est sur une
consommation kilowatt-heure de 350 sur
l'année dernière en diminuant cette
année on va passer de la moitié moins
sur un budget globalement de 85 euros
donc c'est pas exorbitant question plus
que budgétaire d'image où on se sentait
obligé on peut pas dire à nos
concitoyens à nos associations faites ce
que je dis mais parce que je fais le
vrai impact sur la facture lui arrivera
avec la nouvelle année c'est pourquoi la
durée des illuminations a été réduite de
6 à 4 semaines sur le 1er janvier 2023
sur Saint Thonon les augmentations des
énergies qu'on va avoir sont de 246%. en
parallèle la durée de fonctionnement des
candélabres de la commune a été réduite
une demi-heure par jour il faut vraiment
regarder de ce côté là quoi tout ce qui
est halogène tous l'éclairage public qui
sont pas encore équipés en LED et non
sur les décors de Noël qui selon lui
brillent à côté par leur sobriété
on va être à trois ou à virgule 5 pour 5
m de l'heure quoi ça met en colère parce
que nous ça consomme pas grand chose et
on est regardé à travers là-dessus alors
que c'est le visuel qui nous casse du
sucre est limites on nous coupe les
vives encore quoi l'artisan travaille
déjà des alternatives encore moins
consommatrices pour l'année prochaine
que je peux récolter moi-même et greffer
ça dans mes motifs et des boules 3D
grâce à l'imprimante 3D voir un
investissement là-dessus pour l'année
prochaine mais vu la conjoncture on
verra en attendant il espère que
certaines communes bretonnes entendront
son appel
[Applaudissements]
les communes justement elles sont
nombreuses à chercher des solutions pour
réduire leur consommation énergétique
exemple concret à Limoges ou la mairie a
entamé il y a 5 ans déjà d'importants
travaux pour rénover l'Hôtel de Ville la
bâtisse historique magnifique comme vous
le voyez sur ces images de la rédaction
de 7 à Limoges se veut désormais
exemplaire en consommation précision
recueillies par l'un de Ruaud sur place
c'est un bâtiment qui date de la fin du
19e donc voilà il est assez
représentatif de ce type de bâtiment qui
ont été construits à cette époque là ça
on a diagnostiqué l'ensemble des
menuiseries une à une avec des relevés
assez précis on a plus dater les
différentes phases mais on a aussi fait
une étude thermodynamique du bâtiment
donc c'est à dire une modélisation du
bâtiment et de son fonctionnement jour
par jour dans l'année en fonction de
leur surveillement la température
extérieure le chauffage intérieur
Christian Cambon était l'invité de
l'émission Face au territoire sur TV5
Monde jeudi dernier le sénateur
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées du Sénat et notamment revenus sur
les nouvelles tensions liées à la guerre
en Ukraine regardez cette extrait il
appelle beaucoup les États à le soutenir
en terme d'armement est-ce que la France
a fait assez sur ce plan là
elle fait tout ce qu'elle peut elle fait
tout ce qu'elle peut j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que nous avions une armée qui
avait été éreintée par 20 ans de
difficultés donc c'est assez compliqué
de donner ce que nous n'avons plus tout
à fait sauf les César alors les César
alors mais derrière les Césars la France
a donné aussi beaucoup alors elle a une
attitude qu'il faut aussi comprendre
pour des raisons de sécurité
la France ne dit pas tout ce qu'elle
fait parce que d'abord il y a des
problèmes d'acheminement et on n'a pas
envie de renseigner les adversaires de
l'Ukraine sur les chemins que suivent
les approvisionnements de notamment les
approvisionnements en armes il y a des
il y a des moyens importants qui sont
faits il y a des formations qui sont
offertes aussi à des militaires
ukrainiens et elle s'avère aussi très
efficace il y a c'est vrai ces annoncent
César qui change et qui changent de
situation mais on ne peut pas s'aligner
par rapport aux États-Unis qui ont
évidemment des moyens tout à fait
conséquents
face au territoire avec le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères du
Sénat Christian Cambon est à voir ou à
revoir sur le site de TV5 Monde et des
partenaires de l'émission Ouest-France
Nice-Matin France anti 20 minutes et
Centre France la montagne
sans transition prenons la direction de
la Guyane à présent ou la construction
d'une centrale électrique et l'objet de
toutes les tensions dans l'ouest de la
région le projet est notamment rejeté
par des membres de la communauté
amérindienne de Guyane il demande
l'arrêt définitive des travaux et le
déplacement de l'usine vers un autre
site la société chargée du projet espère
bien quant à elle ouvrir la centrale
dans un peu moins de deux ans le point
sur la situation avec ce reportage sur
place de Franck Chassagne
ils se sont installés ici il y a des
décennies des habitants du village
amérindien de prospérité située à 10 km
de saint-laurent-du-maronis ont révoltés
leur espace de vie est aujourd'hui
menacé au cœur du problème
l'installation d'une centrale électrique
à proximité de leur habitation c'est une
forêt qui est utilisée depuis à plus de
30 ans maintenant par les familles de
village prospérité pour se nourrir et
pour ne pas tomber dans la précarité et
puis pour faire c'est un espace de
transmission également de savoir
traditionnels soutenu par les
délégations de Cayenne du Haut-Maroni de
l'Oyapoc du Suriname et bien sûr des
environs de Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni ce
combat qui a commencé il y a plusieurs
années et aujourd'hui au point mort le
24 octobre dernier 4 militants avaient
été placés en garde à vue avant d'être
relâché alors aujourd'hui ils ont décidé
de reprendre leur terrain
depuis 2017 de toutes les façons
l'autorisation a été donnée depuis 2019
même en amont en 2019 ils ont tombé
d'accord sur ce projet là entre signe un
document pour dire voilà c'est ici que
ça va se faire ce projet mais jamais de
consultation avant de signer quelque
chose déterminer les manifestants
exigent que l'ensemble des machines
quitte définitivement leur forêt pour
eux un autre terrain doit être trouvé il
y a plein d'endroits qui peuvent
convenir qui sont pas trop loin des
lieux d'habitation par exemple s'il faut
absolument des collines il se trouve
qu'entre mana et j'avoué juste ce qu'il
faut comme zone colinéaire de son côté
la si haut que l'entreprise privée
désignée pour exploiter le site assure
de construire une centrale high-tech et
respectueuse de l'environnement quant à
son emplacement il n'a pas été choisi au
hasard tout le monde a un peu son avis
bien sûr et chacun a son avis sur les
choses le la zone de mana n'est pas très
intéressante nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de nous raccorder au carrefour
Margot de façon alimentaire
principalement Saint Laurent nous avons
pendant des années étudié l'ensemble des
possibilités et le salaire que ce lieu
est le meilleur déplacez le projet
signifie annuler le projet annuler le
projet veut dire qu'il n'y aura pas
d'électricité pour la population de
Saint-Laurent à l'horizon 2 ans
aujourd'hui les travaux de défrichement
sont à l'arrêt le bras de fer entre les
habitants et la direction de la centrale
est loin d'être réglée l'ouverture de la
centrale électrique est prévue en
octobre 2024
c'est l'un des secteurs qui a le plus
subi les effets de la pandémie les parcs
d'attraction et de loisirs retrouvent le
sourire après deux années pour le moins
très compliqué dans l'Aube le parc
Nigloland vient de fermer ses portes il
y a quelques jours pour une pause
hivernale la saison 2022 lui a permis de
battre son record de fréquentation un
reportage de Canal 32 regardez
c'est la tradition les derniers
visiteurs de la saison de Nigloland
peuvent repartir avec les citrouilles du
décor un souvenir de plus pour cette
saison 2022 du parc d'attraction de
Dolancourt elle s'est refermée ce
dimanche soir sur un record plus de 760
000 visiteurs c'est 100000 de plus que
l'ancien record 2 ans qu'on avait pas
ouvert le parc à Pâques c'est la
precovide les gens ont besoin de sortir
donc ils ont peut-être surconsommer les
sites de loisirs comme Nigloland ou
d'autres endroits ça a été les 35 ans au
mois de juin avec une grande fête on a
fait aussi un été record avec une
fréquentation assez impressionnante pour
la première fois également la période
nigloween c'est prolongée jusqu'à la
mi-novembre mais cette fréquentation
record il faut aussi la gérer le
week-end du 1er novembre le parc
d'attraction a même dû fermer ses
entrées car il était déjà plein avec de
longues minutes d'attente aux
attractions et des équipements pas
encore adaptés à la foule des très
grands jours faut qu'on améliore notre
accueil en restauration faut qu'on
augmente la capacité dans les sanitaires
les toilettes du parc notre aide
améliorer les parkings les accès mettre
des bornes électriques voilà mais c'est
niglons de plus 35 ans c'est ça c'est à
chaque année c'est comment on améliore
tout pas que les attractions pour gérer
au mieux l'influence le parc est en
discussion avec un opérateur l'idée d'un
système de pré-réservation pour avoir le
jour en attendant Krampus expédition
noisette Express le donjon de l'extrême
mais aussi les attractions pour les plus
jeunes séduisent donc de plus en plus un
modèle qui doit perdurer même si Niglo
et niglotte reste très discret sur les
investissements futurs cela annonce pour
le moment l'envie de mettre en avant le
spectacle pyrotechnique de fin de
journée pendant la période d'Halloween
le feu d'artifice est devenu un
spectacle nocturne avec une histoire une
voix off une musique spécialement
composée vous avez passé des heures dans
le parc à attendre à faire des manèges
dans le froid ou dans le chaud ou sous
la pluie mais peu importe le spectacle
c'est tous les soirs à la même heure il
y a pas d'attente la seule attente
aujourd'hui est celle de du parc ce sera
le 8 avril 2023
c'est le rendez-vous sportif de cette
fin d'année la Coupe du monde de
football est organisée au Qatar jusqu'au
18 décembre personne ne peut l'ignorer
et à quelques jours de leur entrée dans
la compétition la pression monte pour
les supporters de l'équipe de France une
nouvelle victoire finale des Bleus dans
un mois et les ventes des maillots
pourraient une nouvelle fois bondir à la
proche de Noël à ce propos
connaissez-vous le concept le bon
maillot l'idée est simple offrir un
coffret mystère qui renferme un maillot
de foot d'un club français ou étranger
le concept a rapidement trouvé son
public aux quatre coins du monde une
idée de cadeau que nous fait découvrir
Anthony Sapp et Anne Didier pour vos
jeux télévision
on a plusieurs plusieurs maillots donc
là par exemple chez field donc tout ce
qui est Angleterre on a Stade de Reims
plus de 150 références des maillots de
foot des quatre coins du monde bientôt
ranger au hasard dans des coffrets
mystères vous commandez vous recevez et
vous découvrez seulement à ce moment-là
ce qui vous a été attribué c'est le
concept original lancé en 2021 par
Timothée ici à l'image et Louis absent
au moment du tournage de vos Giens des
copains d'enfance des amoureux du ballon
devenu en quelques mois de jeunes
entrepreneurs à succès l'idée était
simple il suffisait juste d'y penser la
magie des réseaux sociaux a fait le
reste on a vendu notre premier maillot
en juillet 2021 et les ventes ont
décollé au mois de mars 2022
avec l'effet TikTok et du coup grâce à
ce réseau on a fait on est passé à des
commandes à 100 commandes par mois à 500
commandes par mois puis 1000 puis 2000
puis 3000 et là aujourd'hui on est
autour des 4000 commandes par mois le
bon maillot c'est le nom de cette jeune
société vosgienne qui travaille avec
plusieurs fournisseurs à l'international
les démarques officielles mais depuis
quelques mois ce sont les clubs
professionnels eux-mêmes qui sollicitent
Timothée et Louis notamment
Wolverhampton ou leads en Angleterre
pour un partenariat gagnant-gagnant nous
on a un peu plus de 100 000 visites par
mois actuellement et ils ont on met leur
petit logo sur notre site de manière à
ce qui est-ce que ça soit visible et ça
les intéresse de travailler avec nous
parce qu'effectivement il y a du trafic
et ça les met aussi en avant du coup
l'ascension de la plateforme est
fulgurante avec des chiffres qui
s'envolent depuis sa création on a fait
un peu plus de 800.000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires depuis le départ donc depuis
plus d'un an et demi et on vise un
million cinq d'ici juin 2023 Timothée et
Louis ont embauché trois salariés et
travaillent pour le moment dans deux
petits locaux mais il faudra rapidement
déménager et embaucher encore pour
suivre un rythme qui va s'accélérer
grâce à l'effet Coupe du Monde d'abord
grâce ensuite un coup marketing lancé
pour l'occasion trois tickets d'or
d'argent et de bronze vont être glissés
dans des boîtes mystères pour faire
gagner au plus chanceux différents
cadeaux
voilà et au pied du sapin dans quelques
semaines vous trouverez aussi sûrement
un ou plusieurs livres parmi les ventes
à succès en ce moment l'écrivaine
Catherine Millet vient de se voir
discerner le prix Castel pour son roman
commencement publié chez Flammarion vous
voyez à l'écran quelques images de cette
cérémonie dans cet ouvrage l'auteur
raconte notamment ses débuts dans le
monde de l'art contemporain et les
nombreuses rencontres faites dans ce
milieu voilà une autre idée de cadeau à
faire à l'approche des fêtes
elle rêve elle toutes de la couronne
Miss France la soirée suivie chaque
année par des millions de
téléspectateurs se tiendra le 17
décembre prochain et en attendant de
savoir qui deviendra Miss France 2023
les candidates se préparent pour le jour
J en Martinique Axel René enchaîne les
shootings photos avant de s'envoler pour
l'Hexagone les coulisses de cette
dernière ligne droite nous sont
racontées par Marlène mec pour via ATV
Martinique sur place
[Musique]
sous l'oeil du photographe Axel René
enchaîne les pôles élus le 24 septembre
dernier la jeune Miss Martinique a déjà
pris ses marques et évolue avec
assurance devant le directeur artistique
et son équipe pour ce dernier shooting
au pays Kevin O'Brian a choisi de mettre
en avant à la fois des créations locales
et dans l'air du temps nous avons
travaillé avec des créations de
créateurs locaux j'ai aussi mis à
contribution quelques tenues donc de mes
collections de manière à pouvoir lui
créer ce tout un panel effectivement de
look de style pour qu'elle puisse avoir
des images pour valoriser la Martinique
et par la même aussi développer sa
popularité un travail sur l'image dans
un cadre choisi avec soin la Villa Kawan
aux trois idées à l'avantage de
permettre des mises en lumière très
variées il reflète bien la Martinique à
travers déjà de ces couleurs on a un
super beau temps on a aussi un peu de un
peu de plage maquillage coiffure
styliste une dizaine de personnes
s'affaire autour de la jeune femme de 21
ans soutenu par sa maman jamais très
loin une journée qu'Axel René vit comme
un réveil éveillé je me suis sentie très
bien pendant cette journée de shooting
j'ai tourné plusieurs vidéos pendant
laquelle j'ai dû répondre à diverses
questions j'ai aussi la chance d'avoir
beaucoup de personnes autour de moi pour
me maquiller pour me coiffer donc ça
fait toujours plaisir et ça permet de se
rendre compte de
du rêve que j'ai réalisé en devenant
Miss France Miss Martinique faut-il
abscisse ce rêve là Axel René va le
toucher du doigt très bientôt la
candidate martiniquaise à l'élection de
Miss France prend son départ dès demain
pour la préparation officielle de la
soirée du 17 décembre
voilà rendez-vous donc pris pour les 30
candidates le 17 décembre prochain pour
l'élection de Miss France 2023 on sera
tous devant notre écran bien sûr sans
transition dans ce journal
intéressons-nous à présent à un métier
historique en voie de disparition celui
de rémouleur aiguisé les lames de
couteau de ciseaux ou de n'importe quel
objet tranchant c'est l'activité de
cette artisan souvent ambulant
d'ailleurs dans la Sarthe un seul
rémouleur est encore mobile grâce à une
camionnette aménagée rencontre avec
Anthony python journaliste pour LM TV
Sarthe
le geste est précis efficace au fur et à
mesure des passages sur la meule la lame
retrouve son tranchant dans sa
camionnette aménagée Philippe prépare
tout ce qu'il coupe les couteaux les
ciseaux et toutes sortes d'outils en
acier ou en fer tremper la différence
qu'on peut faire c'est l'usage qu'on va
faire de l'outil par exemple quand on
prend un couteau on a Faita pas un
trancheur comme on a vu train années
plus cher et on a vu trois fois un
ciseau de couture comme on a fait 86 ans
de coiffure voilà chaque outil à sa bien
sa spécificité et donc son style
d'affûtage et son angle d'affûtage
surtout
Philippe est l'un des seuls rémouleurs
en Sarthe et surtout le seul rémouleur
ambulant tous les mercredis s'accumulait
se pose sur le marché de la flèche et
les clients ne manquent pas
on peut chez soi mais après ça coupe pas
au bout de trois quatre fois donc très
bien hormis cette clientèle de
particuliers que je retrouve ici j'ai
essentiellement une clientèle de
professionnels parce qu'il est
essentiellement après effectivement dans
les métiers de bouche
restaurateurs boucherie traiteur
couturière coiffeuse voilà tous ces gens
qui utilisent des outils coupants ont
des besoins d'entretien et d'affûtage
réguliers de bonne qualité pourtant il y
a quelques années les rémouleurs avaient
totalement disparu en Sarthe l'époque
n'était plus à la réparation des vieux
couteaux mais d'après Philippe
aujourd'hui la tendance s'inverse on est
passé par une société de congrès de
consommation importante
ont beaucoup en reviennent et beaucoup
avec les budgets qui se réduisent tout
le monde va commence à réutiliser à
redonner une deuxième vie et à réparer
le rémouleur est aussi présent sur des
parkings de centre commerciaux c'est le
cas au moment tous les deuxièmes jeudis
du mois devant le magasin metro
histoire encore dans ce journal avec le
soulagement des habitants de Villemur
sur Tarn en Haute-Garonne la bas une
friche historique est magnifique à
l'abandon depuis presque 10 ans vient de
retrouver un repreneur une nouvelle vie
pour ce site de près de 8000 mètres
carrés qui a fait la fierté de la
commune pendant des décennies jusqu'à
600 salariés et travailler sur place
pour la production notamment de
biscottes et de pattes alimentaires le
nouveau projet porté par le groupe essor
mixera logement commerce et bureau image
spectaculaires des lieux et interviews
récoltés par Manon aussi pour la Dépêche
du Midi notre partenaire sur place
les bureaux l'entrée principale les
bureaux avec une partie une partie pour
le personnel et une partie bureau pour
le pour les clients c'est une bâtiment
qui me passionne depuis toujours et
la crainte qu'on avait c'était que
progressivement il soit détruit ce
tournant je crois que c'est sur les 30
dernières années c'est vraiment
l'élément essentiel de la sauvegarde de
ce bâtiment elle est quand même assez
extraordinaire
allez on referme ce journal avec une
pâtisserie pour le moins gourmandes et
indissociable de la culture
gastronomique de la Somme le gâteau
battu c'est son nom est une spécialité
aussi riche vous allez le voir en
calories que délicieuse des œufs de la
levure de la farine du sucre et du
beurre il n'en faut pas plus même si il
en faut beaucoup pour confectionner ce
gâteau ses secrets de fabrication vous
sont dévoilés par Jérémy houblon pour
rouet au TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord
qui s'est rendue dans une boulangerie
spécialisée et qui s'est régalé regardez
il représente peut-être à lui seul
l'identité de la Picardie Maritime et
oui rares sont ceux qui boudent le
moelleux d'un bon gâteau battu bah oui
c'est d'ailleurs la texture tout ça
c'est bien ça change aussi l'odeur quand
elle vient d'être cuit c'est très
agréable à Quesnoy le montant
prédapteville le gâteau battu est une
spécialité depuis 1956 on mélange ici
les quelques ingrédients nécessaires à
sa confection un peu de sucre pas mal de
farine de la levure des jaunes d’œufs et
du beurre en grosse quantité pour vous
donner le ratio une brioche on a un kilo
de farine pour 500 g de beurre
d'accord moi sur le battu je suis un
kilo de farine pour 1 kg de beurre je
suis un point chaque jour près de 900
gâteaux battus sortent du laboratoire de
Nicolas amourette en 15 ans d'expérience
il a tout appris que la recette et de
son histoire un gâteau battu avant
s'appelait le gâteau mollet qui venait
des Flandres et qui a été
au travail sur sur la région et là à
partir de 200900 ils ont vraiment c'est
devenu spécialités régionales
historiquement le gâteau battu était
servi à l'occasion de mariage ou de vins
d'honneur et surtout l'été car il lui
faut de la chaleur de la chaleur et un
bon coup de main à trois reprises après
les avoir laissé se reposer il faut
donner à ses 40 kg de pâtes ce qu'on
appelle un tour à la pâte elle était
inerte elle avait pas de force donc
l'objectif c'est de lui donner de la
force et pour ça il faut le battre donc
double terme gâteau battu la pâte est
ensuite moulée pour à nouveau se reposer
c'est là qu'elle prendra sa forme
emblématique dernière étape la cuisson
au four 17 minutes à 170 degrés
en tout il aura fallu presque trois
heures de travail avant d'apprécier la
qualité du produit quand le gâteau
dévoile sa patte alvé au lait et ses
senteurs vous pouvez voir qu'il est
moelleux parce qu'en fait j'ai du mal à
couper idéalement c'est de le laisser
assez un petit peu quoi ne reste plus
qu'à l'apprécie
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous et à bientôt
[Musique]